can I just say Yes um I think it's
interesting that you have this approach
now I came across a video of you where
you was talking about
um interracial marriage in such a
degrading and denigrating manner but
they were pointing at each other yeah
and the song goes something like break
up your back broke off your back okay so
this is for all of the Somali Community
um I've let them know that I was coming
on and they wanted to know and they
believed that you have something against
the Somali community in particular the
Somali women so can you answer this
alley because this is literally what
they want to know it's called so this is
the seven day period where the woman and
the husband don't leave their home so
the food is brought to them they don't
do anything so they're still handing me
traditionally traditionally speaking
people have this mentality today if my
wedding is not trending on social media
I didn't have a wedding promise how the
world lie to her lighter and then when
you actually get my return you've got
her now present Your Truth when it comes
to Somali weddings yeah in a appropriate
clothing style free mixing I mean it's
like you are attending a nightclub or a
music festival I think as much as we're
lenient with divorce in comparison to
other communities we're also frowned
upon it as well there are people that
are still very very strong in in their
Kabir and they were like we're not going
to marry this cabin we're not going to
marry that obviously
if a woman is not sexually satisfied she
has a right to divorce be patient on
your husband you know regardless of what
he does that same level of um sort of
advice it's not given to the men's
so guys if you are somebody who trains
like me when I'm doing boxing when I'm
joking when I'm doing bodybuilding this
can benefit you it's shilajit from
Nature's Blends as you guys know I get
my honey my black seed oil and many
other supplements from them it has 86
plus minerals including zinc magnesium
selenium fulvic acid and 59 fully lab
tested the highest in the market boost
testosterone levels Boost energy levels
and safe for men and women so check out
Nature's Blends in the description box
and enjoy it
the most merciful the most trust or
praise His glory and gratitude belong to
him
um and welcome to the bitter truth show
as you guys can see we are here talking
uh on variety of topics but the team
came with an idea we thought you know
what why don't we do a cultural one
where enough will be very intriguing
because I want to know about different
cultures so we thought you know why
don't we do you know and we've done a
post so we said
um bengalis Jamaicans somalis and
Moroccans so number one number one was
Moroccans then it was bengales and then
it was somalis and then lastly I think
it was Jamaicans but then what happened
is the mongolis uh didn't really apply
that much so then before we go to
somalis so we're here today
um and some Moroccans uh canceled was
one of us Moroccan episode but it got
canceled because uh people say they turn
up and they don't turn up uh but it's
fine because from now we implemented 50
pound deposits which means you're paying
50 pounds and if you come in the day
I'll be giving you your money back if
not uh
so um in a nutshell today's episode I'm
really excited because
um the community for example it's we're
going to be talking about the Somali
culture I want to know everything about
the Somali culture okay because there's
a lot of like for example my Quran
teachers at Somali a lot of my brothers
so in a nutshell as you guys know the
rule so there's the bitter buzzers I
don't think this is an episode where
it's gonna we're gonna debate I don't
think there's going to be a debate I
don't think so it's just going to be a
topic where we will just be talking but
if you disagree with whoever it may be
you press the buzzer and you have one
and a half minute nobody can interrupt
you and you'll have your say so the
first question is basically in a
nutshell because we don't know about
your culture so we've got our brothers
Muhammad came all the way from Sweden
uh you're from the UK
and our honorable sisters uh who live in
the UK right yeah yeah perfect may Allah
bless you guys inshallah our sisters for
coming so let me just open the
discussion the first thing that I would
personally read as the team would want
to know and we asking the same questions
every Culture by the way it's nothing
you know every course is the same
questions when it comes to seeking
marriage in the Somali Community how
does it work for example does the
parents say you know find someone
suitable do they get involved please
just give me the address I just want to
know from the Somali culture I don't
know who should start with the sisters
or the come on this okay we'll start
with the championship okay tell us when
it comes to the Somali Community the
first question to you guys how do you
guys go about finding someone in your
culture
thank you foreign
let's break it down how does the Somali
marriage work
when a Somali boy meets a Somali girl
yeah and the Sparks Fly it's time for
some serious matchmaking action yeah the
families they step in like referees
negotiating Dowry Financial agreements
like this is a World Cup final once the
deal is sealed yeah and it's time for
the big day yeah picture this a vibrant
Somali wedding
cultural dancing wild epic music I mean
food drinks everywhere that's it yeah
okay all right so that was that was I
was gonna say that was a very good style
you brought life to the studio so just
rewind it a bit how for example if you
are looking to seek marriage
where does the parents get involved how
is the initiating process like for
example like yourself you're not married
okay okay if you was to if you can bring
my clothes so if you was looking to get
married actually for you would you be
like okay if you're interested in a
Somali system would you be like would
you get your does your family find
somebody because look in the Asian
culture it's more like a reference or I
know somebody my cousin or you need to
go marry the cousin that you know like
those things you hear them but in the
Somali culture is that the same thing
um I mean personally if if I wanted to
get married I wouldn't
um I'll probably go to with my parents
if I'm being very honest because I would
oh you wouldn't I would go to my place
so I'll probably ask them for advice on
who to pick I've never done it before so
I can't really speak from experience but
in my family I've packed for a big
family so I've got like 10 10 siblings
so 19 weeks all together with ten
um so
it's very like some of my brothers and
sisters got married to arranged
marriages so through my parents and then
some of them just found spouses
themselves okay in in the Somali culture
is it is it like this there's a parent
say listen we will arrange this for you
or do they give you that for example
argument's sake you go to a family
gathering do they say okay you know what
actually you know that girl or that boy
does that happen I just like culturally
like I feel like it doesn't like it's
not like um in comparison to perhaps the
Asian Community where it's really big on
arranged marriage yes I think with the
Somali Community we're very we're not as
strict so it's not frown upon if a girl
brings
um a man and says mom dad I met this guy
this is who I want to marry they do a
background check and vice versa if the
boy does it so it's not really
um
strict like that we're very we're very
flexible yeah I mean the only time yeah
I think we are quite strict and is in in
relation into tribalism right
yeah so say for instance
um this doesn't really happen as often
in the west but it happens a lot back
home where say for instance
um you know a system may want to get
married to a brother and then the family
may not necessarily be too fond of him
mainly because of the fact that he's
from a different from a different tribe
and because of that they may instantly
decline uh his uh you know him wanting
to marry her so
tribe does come into play but it doesn't
happen as often and that's the only part
I think we're strict in for the most
part okay we're going to come to the
interracial marriages good point martial
good point so I so from what I've got
just am I correct to say that today I
have learned that when it comes to
seeking marriage the Somali Community
does not have life okay you know what
you need to marry your cousin or you
need to marry this person or like the
family the parents are not very like no
you're going to marry who I see it's
more like okay
um arguments say bro um
if you see a Somali sister and you're
like you know what this sister looks
marriage material how would you initiate
the process to your parents like how
would you go about it would you be like
you know what
um then you speak to them to speak to
the family to both of you guys I don't
know who wants to answer first so do you
mean like on the street or I wouldn't
yeah no I don't imagine you said you
found a girl yourself yeah or how would
you tell your parents yeah or in a
wedding maybe would they say no what
would they say how would you go about
doing it a young truck this one dudes
I'll probably
I'm trying to get hold of her father so
I wouldn't really first I'll tell my
parents I'll put one like what's
happening basically but
um I'll be more so just explain to them
like I found somebody suitable and then
I'll tell them to
I'll try and get hold of the father of
the Goldfish that's what I would do okay
100. so emergency stop you argument say
a wedding or imagine your mom's friend
is dropped by her son and you happen to
see him yeah and you're like you know I
seems like a good problem
um would you go to like I think Hoyle
would you go to higher or is it Apple no
yeah okay and would you come and say you
know what I I want I'm interested in how
would you initiate it like
I don't think we really do that I'll be
honest with you girls don't really do
that they would probably not okay yeah
they would not do that
they'll try and find maybe
um like somebody that will have
background information about him like
okay like is he married is he not
married what's his background but not
really it's not like it's not really
normal for us to speak to our parents
about guys that we like um okay it's
really like it's still very super
conservative okay yeah so so you would
basically at what point would you go to
the parents so would you go like for
example when you're about to get married
okay so so you're seeing when you're
like the last bit exactly yeah okay so
the background checks would it be done
for like friends is it like okay you
know what that brother the sisters
most of the times no no before we go to
the parents so sorry brother or sister
are you interested in would you get your
cousin or your sister or your brother to
to be like okay who is that brother like
is it like that yeah sometimes that does
occur yeah so say for instance if they
mean no one another or if if he may know
of him it would be better to ask him oh
do you know anything about him do I need
to be wary of this person and so and so
forth so in that respect yeah okay
perfect anything else no I agree with
them okay perfect wow second second
question second question from it okay
once a prospective spouse has been
identified how do the Somali culture
like the navigate the process from the
initial encounter from Encounter of the
day of wedding so in a nutshell now you
found the person he is the or she is the
one
can you tell me for example how do you
guys go about asking for the hand what
guys what do you guys do like in in our
Turkish Kurdish culture it's mainly they
you go with life you know baklavascript
you get the baklavas and you're just
like okay I'm gonna go ask for the
girl's hand yeah and there's some
cultural things where the deal puts like
salt in your Turkish coffee if she
doesn't like you or something like that
yeah yeah to show like if it's extra
sweet it means I can't remember but in a
nutshell
how do you guys go about it from the
initiating process
um to speaking to the family how does
asking the hand happen and then we'll
talk about the marriage Etc
yeah
we follow Islamic beliefs right
the Islamic way and um
ask the father for the hand Etc
and it's not something special it's an
Islamic ways okay easy nothing out of
the order
so I would say and it's straight up in
the car fathers have us as the father
Halas okay but it's different okay so
it's a bit different okay can I hear it
I think it just depends um are we
talking from a traditional aspect we're
just talking like tradition let's get to
the tradition today like Islamic needs
no I mean that's culturally
traditionally for example who goes to
ask for the hand is it the mom for
example Entourage where it's like you've
got the brothers and uncles and you've
got the mom and they go sit with it like
how does it work who goes there first I
want to know culture is this at the just
before the marriage or just when you're
about no no this is this is basically
saying you're not opening up it's like
this is the person I'm interested in
you're going to basically either they're
coming to us for your hand well that's
the main way so from your point of view
he will come to us for the hand for the
brothers they'll be going so the boys
the boys family would normally come to
the um the woman's house just men or is
it woman everywhere um so it will be
both but they will be in separate rooms
okay good but initially if we're just
talking about you know letting the man
sort of asking for the girl's hand in
marriage it will be him he's Dad if he's
alive he's brother like men that he
really trust in his family he's his
brother his dad his uncle and maybe
actually or is that too early uh I don't
know I think it depends because um
traditionally speaking yeah you're right
in that aspect so typically speaking the
men the male relatives come so it's
different in each region so I'm talking
about so true so for the South right uh
for us people what's the difference I
want to know between the South and North
like what's the difference in the north
are like somalilanders okay so what's
what's the is there a big difference
with the cultural aspect a little slight
differences slight difference yeah there
are some differences I mean go on slight
explain I don't know what the difference
I mean if there is any difference what
do you what okay let's clarify you're
from the south is that right and I'm
from the north what do you do what do
you guys do when you when the man
traditionally speaking Yeah typically
speaking so what happens is the male
relatives
um go to the uh woman's house right and
they basically you know introduce the
boy they talk about him in a good manner
they say this is what he does so so on
and so forth and if the father accepts
The Proposal they pay something called
something like that so it's basically
like a small amounts of money uh to
basically as a gratitude as a form of
gratitude okay who pays this so stop the
the
um the the man so his father or his
relatives so let me get this right if
he's interested in a sister his father
would pay the the girl's father yeah
yeah so the girl the girl is paid
typically so it's like a as a form of
gratitude this is just it's not this is
good see that's why I want to know okay
so culturally this is what happened so
the his father argument said he will pay
the girl's father as a form of gracious
gratitude yeah wow okay and is there a
specific amount or can it be can you
have any money it could be anything
really it can be any gift yeah yeah okay
perfect Karen and uh yeah so then once
the girl uh accepts the you know the
amount and the father approves of the
approach the proposal then we go ahead
with the with the Nika and then we go
ahead with the uh you know to her
choosing whatever she asks for and then
we go ahead with the with the wedding
and then it's like a whole process
traditionally speaking again there's
like a it's like a whole process
um the Shasta let's let's go I want to
know from the get-go okay there's a lot
I wanna everything because to me it's
enlightening so the the gift has been
given the they have agreed that they're
getting married does the captain first
is there a like how many um
celebrations you have like how many um
stages like yeah like for instance I
want to know for example uh like I did
hear that the girl wears different
dresses like I don't know I thought can
you I want to know please go follow I
just want to know everything everything
yeah please God I just want to know come
babe how did it go I don't really so um
again it's different for each region
right so what happens is uh so once in a
car it's been done yeah what happens is
the father sometimes uh he may be there
uh in his daughter's absence offenses he
may be there uh you know
yes as a spokesperson yeah as a
spokesperson for his daughter and then
once everything the process and
everything the procedure and everything
goes well then we go ahead with the
wedding and then the wedding takes place
and then the wedding it's a long process
procedure
I want to know like yeah them had of
course uh you know the same ahead
happens given yeah prior to the wedding
of course
then can I just say that's Western no
this is traditional this is tradition
well the white dress no no I'm gonna
talk about the words it's given prior to
the wedding so it's the nikah happens so
the mat is given before yeah no no the
nikah is done and then the matter is
given okay of course the man is given
yeah after that what is the first
celebration dude is it like where the
the females come together and celebrates
it what happens so we're quite
conservative
um so what happens is the men are on one
side and then the women are on the other
side so the women typically speaking
they come in celebration they dance and
you know we have something called
brambur which is basically a celebration
of poetry yeah poetry and dancing and so
on and so forth and then the men they
just sit together they eat which is
quite boring really or you can do much
yeah but you know the women you know
they basically celebrate and then the
girl like you said earlier she um
changes you know three times the
container which is the traditional okay
wait wait I need to break this down
what's the first one called so the first
one um it can be you know any stage so
the first one is the Contino what does
that mean gantino is basically a
traditional Somali Italian so which is
something that Somali women are known
for wearing okay and then it could be
the white dress you know okay so it can
be okay
yeah it can be that but yeah so okay
um since this is the bitter truth show
yeah
I need to be honest and I'm gonna sound
a bit negative yeah all right when it
comes to Somali weddings yeah especially
in this day and age
I see a lot of Fitness going on yeah so
what do I mean inappropriate clothing
style free mixing I mean it's like you
are attending a nightclub or a music
festival it's all about capturing the
moment yeah the latest Tick Tock Trend
and do the dancers Etc and I remember I
saw this video a couple of months ago
yeah
scrolling saw this video with this
Somali couple newly married yeah were
dancing in the wedding I don't know what
the name of the song is yeah but they
were pointing at each other yeah and the
song goes something like break off your
back brack off your back yeah and listen
to me everybody yeah the aunties the
elders everybody in the community was
looking at them with this look of this
taste yeah and what's going on what's
happening to our culture yeah they call
it the bombastic side eye yeah
so yeah and this is what's going on yeah
so let's ask ourselves good questions
where does this problem stems from
Yani people have this mentality today if
my wedding is not trending on social
media I didn't have a wedding
so what you are doing now is you are
compromising your Islamic beliefs just
to have a big wedding and yeah there is
no barca in this type of marriages this
is what's going on in the Somali
Community we need to speak more about
this
um bro we need you more on the show
please yeah um I'm really uh I would
love you to be on the show mashallah I
think there's a lot of points you I
agree with because if I look into my
culture we've been assimilated so much I
I don't think if you saw what the Turks
are doing now actually you would you
would say hamdullah we are doing very
good we're
understood something it's like a
nightclub and a full out I'll call music
the way they drive my mom tells me yes
your Auntie's wedding I'm saying mommy
I'm sorry I'm not going nowhere near
that not with the vicinity if it's there
I'm going around the block yeah so it's
it's okay I see and that is true that's
a lot of uh people are sadly like you
said people just I feel sometimes the
marriage is the the wedding and that's
what they they get divorced I've heard
of stories where like because the focal
point is what big wedding
and then when they get into the actual
marriage they're like oh this is boring
but so you said sister the first thing
was that dress and then
um they wear something else why do they
do three types of clothing is it just
like it's just it's just part of the uh
the wedding so it's just part of Somali
wedding it again it's it's dependent
upon the woman sometimes you may just
opt for one dress it depends on who she
is right yeah okay so what about this
religiously oh it depends if she's
religious if she comes around religious
family or if it's more culturally so
you're from the north sister so you said
is it similar
I think so it must be very smart
what's different because I
it's there's just I don't know what they
traditionally traditionally do back home
yeah in the UK like when I got married I
mean like I wasn't even there for when
the guy came here I wasn't there I was
at work actually oh interesting okay
yeah so they gave me away without me
being there yeah
but you you was slightly uh I mean
you're not supposed to be there that's
what they say ah see good okay so you're
not supposed to be there I mean it
depends it depends really ever I don't
know but you was honestly you wanted to
marry the girl but you're fired yeah so
okay so can I ask you know when you do
the wedding is it like one wedding one
time and three dresses yeah what is it
before you have to do this
you guys have like this henna night
well you don't
know
[Music]
I don't know but basic well if you're if
you're in the west I think probably yeah
[Music]
so it's just one word in three dresses
the men just eat the the the the Somali
sisters they just do have a party for
the Sisters yeah yeah we have we have
that and then towards the end we have
something called I think you know so
this is basically uh when you know
married women although again some women
don't do this but married women go
around the um the bride and they
basically put on different colored silk
uh scarves it's almost like wood off uh
any sort of like evil eye or you know
divorce or whatever but then again for
religious reasons what about this done
okay that's part of culture yeah yeah
okay that's interesting uh have you been
saying any Somali weddings yeah I've
been to different ones like mixed ones
and then also separate
um
yeah I'm gonna be honest I don't really
know too much about how it works
everyone it's got a different process
um you do get like uh what she's saying
it does happen
um and then you get like mixed ones a
lot more modern nowadays people are
following like modern Trends and like no
Islamic stuff uh because yeah they're
just following my Western World
basically so
yeah okay good all right I think is
there anything else we can add in this
about anything the last part yep please
it's called right so this is the seven
day period the honeymoon traditionally
speaking where the woman and the husband
don't really leave their bedroom right
so they don't leave their home so the
food is brought to them they don't do
anything so they're still handing me
traditionally traditionally speaking so
the whole seven days
yeah so dedicated for them to get to
know each other sort of like Bond and so
on and so forth so that's their honey
wow yeah very that's very interesting
take because
that's pertaining to if you marry a
virgin girl that you should spend an x
amount a couple of days if there's
anyone that remembers I don't know if it
was seven but uh okay so interesting
okay now moving on to
um how does the Somali culture the
community deal with when it comes to
marital disputes so if there's an amount
of difference between the husband and
the wife how do you guys deal with it is
it like for example what I heard was
that basically it's more like um
tell me if I'm wrong yeah they usually
say okay it's your family we stay away
like like I don't know we will only get
involved but it's more like it's a
husband and wife they don't something
like this but please correct me I don't
know I'm absolutely
short yeah
marital disputes and stuff like that
usually it's the elders yeah I need the
elders the aunties who yeah
and religious authorities who facilitate
this process they take care of it they
they are the ones who usually
make sure that hey everything is all
right here everything is good so I mean
it's it's the elders who take care of it
when it comes to American disputes
usually
because we are Somali since we were
young we were thought you need to
respect the elders it doesn't matter how
rich you are how educated you are your
the elders have a important voice listen
to what they say when it comes to
marital dispute
so that's it
so you said basically the Elder the
older you get involved the elders get
involved yeah the aunties the leaders
the dad the mom the dad yeah so if there
is a issue between the husband and wife
the the the traditionally the man will
come the father of the girl would come
and the same for his family so they'll
get together so people that he trusts in
his family people that she trust from
her family they come together they are
also present they both present their
cases and will say what their issues are
and then they try and resolve it okay
um just curious
if
um the Somali uh boy he comes and says
you know I'm not happy with my wife what
would the parents be like what do you
think culturally the aspect is like is
it more like listen
um be quiet or you know what like is it
is it like something where they're like
listen go back to your house what
happens because some cultures can be
like very
toxic in that element where it's you
know I'm trying to say so how do you
guys like to deal with the initial State
imagine the daughter comes home and
she's complaining about her husband do
the parents absorb it listen or is it
more like listen your husband like I
don't know I'm just it depends on which
family but culturally I think they try
as much as they can to try and push them
together like so traditionally our
culture is not one that takes marriage
like lightly like we we do respect and
put such high value in a marriage so we
do try and um you know calm the woman
down try and make her see sense and vice
versa to the man so yeah we do our
culture doesn't see marriage as like a
very light thing so if he says that he
wants to divorce her they'll tell him
calm down you know think about this are
you sure so that we'll try I think you
know that's how we see marriage
interesting yeah
uh yeah I I I agree as well uh I think
as much as we're lenient with divorce in
comparison to other communities we're
also frowned upon it as well especially
um when it comes to divorced women so we
try to as much as we can you know
so come out with Solutions typically
speaking as the Elders of the family uh
the you know the female or the male
relatives whatever it may be whatever we
can do to sort out and bring up
Solutions okay interesting I did hear
like for example they do really like
which one thing another thing that I
really like about the Somalia Community
culture is that they do really push you
to like listen welcome your house
welcome your house you know there is not
like yeah come oh he's done this Etc
let's break the you get it I I feel like
um they do they do really um like push
that I haven't I don't know I haven't I
haven't personally heard um of any like
I don't know like all the girls you go
to mom and her mom just like brainwashes
uh that doesn't happen right it does
depend on like yeah of course yeah yeah
but generally I've heard that they are
very like keep your marriage leave your
marriage yeah more so towards the women
though so it's like if it's a woman it's
like you know keep your husband keep
your you know keep your house all
together I think a lot of the
um keeping the marriage together is most
of the times it's placed upon the woman
right so that responsibility sometimes
is placed upon the woman she's told I'll
make sure you know you know be patient
on your husband you know regardless of
what he does that same level of um sort
of
yeah and you know what sometimes it can
lead
sometimes the sisters to uh feminism
yeah sadly because we have I I have
sometimes seen it where you know it
happens with all kinds of women happen
Etc uh but yeah that's that's a
phenomena where they end up being like
you know what we're not getting our
rights and it's sad because it's not
it's not really Islam both of us should
be given both ways
um so basically in a nutshell anything
else you want to add that no yeah okay
uh next question is basically okay when
it comes to um divorce
so this like you know what look this
talk they're spoken whatever
they're like you know what we don't we
how does the procedure start so they're
like you know what I'm not happy with
this woman oh I'm not happy with him
yeah I want divorce
is there a last resort of look let's
have a meeting like get the families
come together and when it's decided like
okay I want divorce how does that
process start with kids and without kids
so imagine the sister hasn't got kids
they haven't got kids yeah but imagine
they also have kids so
you're at the divorce stage yeah how
does the community in a nutshell deal
with it
society when it comes to divorce divorce
is regarded as a last resort yeah and
its approach with a lot of caution due
to the emphasis of keeping the marital
bond together yeah but when a couple
decides to pursue a divorce usually as I
said before the elders the leaders in
the community religion religious
authorities faciliate the process yeah
and one thing I need to bring in is
I do think that a lot of divorces happen
for any trivial and there if pointless
useless reasons yeah for example a woman
can say hey he used to take me out two
times a week now only two times a month
I feel like the Friendship is growing
apart I don't feel the bond anymore
therefore I'm gonna divorce him yeah so
this there is reasons they happen of
course sometimes yeah it can happen
because of brutal problems abuse
Etc conflicts but usually it's this
useless reasons so yeah and that's my
thoughts on it okay can I just can I
just say something
um I mean
I I keep hearing um that the Somali
Community has a high rate of divorces
and everyone's had a cross-culture yeah
I think it's everyone's name but can I
give my take what I think that is like I
feel like traditionally like back home
in Somalia Somaliland wherever
um women didn't have as many rights as
they do in the UK this is my take right
um women didn't have as much rights as
um they they do here therefore they used
to put up with a lot more
um you know things from men that they
probably 90 of the time won't put up
with from men and I'm I'm really sorry
to tell you Muhammad but that's not
the reason why women get divorced
because of silly little things is often
like major things that men are not
fulfilling like there's a traditional
saying like in Somali where um
yeah we know that we know that person
like marry her with like like her in
with life yeah like promise her the
world lie to her lighter and then when
you actually get my return you've got
her now present your truth please
the one who says hit the road
yeah I heard it she's the one who said
that basically you lied to me you
understand yeah
and that's why a lot of Somali men tend
to do and that's it's a pro it's a
proper for a reason okay I just want to
say something we have a whole topic on
why marriages are breaking down
um I think this issue is not a Somali
issue everyone everybody's going through
it yeah so we're going to discuss that
in the why a marriage is breaking them
if you're going to be there for that
yeah it'll be good to have your take on
it but in general I just want to know
just going back to topic
um how do you guys deal with uh in the
sense so a family just gets involved and
if the girl is adamant is there more
pressure put on the girl to stay or the
boy to stay
can I just yeah okay
I would say like personally I don't like
know anybody like close that's how to
divorce
but from like uh like distant relatives
I've seen like for example my dad would
go to um try and resolve issues with
like the husband and the wife so
um I think yeah it definitely it is fun
to come to have a divorce it's not good
um
and yeah like a person I don't know I
don't know too much about this like
because I've not seen it like around me
like my oldest brother
um basically he's he's got mental
condition so he did have a divorce but
it was more so
just non-compatibility it wasn't really
um
yeah well I'm not like I'm not like
people around me that are like bad
divorces that are like normal okay so if
you guys have heard of any divorce in
your in the community which one is going
to emphasize the woman to stay with the
man to stay like do they say to the
woman oh you know put out with them or
do they because probably are they are
they Fair are they like I think more
with the women I think they try and push
they try and always
yeah but ultimately it's you know it's
the man that gives a talappa isn't it so
if he doesn't and you know there are
times where the man doesn't want to give
the talaq on the woman demands it and
yet she doesn't get it so it just yeah
they do encourage the women more
pressure yeah and the responsibility
like I said earlier it's like solely
placed upon the woman even if her mental
health is deteriorating and she's like
going through it perhaps maybe you've
got a second wife and he's not providing
for her you know maybe he's you know
maybe he's abusing her whatever the case
might be right she's told you know just
keep her husband put up with it you know
this is what you're supposed to do as a
wife you know this is our culture we'll
get better it will get better in time
just go back to your husband you know I
think that's why you see that with the
Asian culture in many cultures yeah
you've seen in many cultures as well but
then again yeah it's it's yeah it's not
it's not it's necessary from Islam
especially if the man is not doing his
rights
um you know if he's not even providing
basic I don't know why these like these
boys didn't think about second wife is
I'm I fall out say it you know we are as
men we are polygaments by Nature 100
billion I don't care anybody that comes
to me I'll challenge anybody we we 100
uh anybody that disagree well no problem
I'm willing to do livestock for anyone
I'm ready to go for it I'll put my neck
on the line every man is polygamous by
Nature every single man so to me the
issue is I'm just talking about the men
who do not provide and violate their
wives right I believe they shouldn't be
talking about this because you're not
even giving the basic hack of your first
wife yeah is she even happy with you
actually I don't even recommend it me
personally I wouldn't recommend it to a
individuals if a brother comes to me and
says I want a second wife and I'm like
listen how's your relation with your
first wife bad broch please my dog fix
that once that is unchecked what I mean
is your relationship the way you then
you have it was sorry about this yeah
you know these things that you have is
yeah
so the thing is um that you need to have
that if you're not then you're basically
causing problems you know of course the
first one is never going to be happy if
you get married again that's a different
issue but at least if you have that nice
balanced relationship if she knows
you're a good man you know she she I
believe if Allah's legislative
politicism Allah's created you in a way
where you can deal with it it is bad but
you'll deal with it just the way I have
to deal when I go to we're in it when we
go to what we have to deal with as well
but how often do you go to war but the
thing is if we do we end up dying and
coming back and our wives will get
married to somebody else yeah so the
issue is our one is actually greater
because if you think about a sister off
topic I'm so sorry I'm a passionate when
it comes to this I got a bad one when it
comes to this issue you
you share a husband when I go and die I
leave an inheritance which my wife and
enjoy with a new husband yeah which one
is worse
case
that's not often anything happens often
okay yes it is but you know why sister
and I say this you know what I say yeah
and I know it's off topic here I say
this to every sister and he says that
comes to me and says my husband is
getting a second wife I have simple
basic questions sister this husband of
yours does he pray Salam yes does he
fast yes this is good is he good to you
good yeah okay does he feel are good
have you ever caught him talking to
girls behind your back or no no none of
that generally good guy he has loving
provides loves the kids I would say you
are out of your mind to end that
marriage because he's getting a second
wife because you know why the problem is
not going to run away the next man you
marry is that it's going to come in
different forms even it's going to be
doing it haram way even he's going to do
a secret or he's going to do it openly
and I honor the man who does it openly
rather than secretly but when I'm seeing
his sister is that
every single man has is polygamous
we'll do a test but do you but do you
agree that some men prefer just that
they they do say that it's ha it's a
headache having two wives or three wives
some men do actually just want one okay
sister no no no sister the moment they
say it's a headache where do you feel
the headache is stemming from the first
wash the moment a man says it's a
headache you know what he's saying not
the headache that if I have two eyes The
Habit my first wife's gonna cause me
because they're they're not saying I'm
happy with my first wife they're seeing
it's the headache yeah okay yeah
[Laughter]
like if a man has one wife there is you
do you know men that have just one wife
and their absolutely let me say
something yeah
I deal with these cases in the sense
where I speak to General I speak to
Japanese people I speak to people who
are God God conscious I speak to
semi-practicing people I speak to people
who do the basic I see one thing in
common all of them how many men are
there one two three four five six seven
are there anybody and sister's husbands
here as well yes unless you've got uh
gone to his head I'm telling you every
single man in here is polygamous
every single man now the man if if he
the only reason why he would argument's
sake will not be looking for that like
you said the headache number two for
example
[Music]
you know why I emphasize on this topic
yeah some people feel like emphasized on
this topic because it's a brother swing
and you know we've got the brother's
side
one of the main reasons I emphasize on
this topic is following yeah because
sisters are living in Disneyland let me
tell you why they think this Romeo
Juliet look Romeo Juliet there's nothing
wrong with it it's a dream
because you guys can't fulfill it is
that what it is yes so what I'm seeing
is this sister yeah me look any man
that's for example it's as good as me
seeing or all of these brothers here
yeah most of them are married here it's
as good as using I'm gonna divorce my
wife because she nags a lot brother the
next woman you're gonna marry is going
to nag a lot and the next one that
you're gonna marry is gonna look am I
running away from the problem no it's
just coming in a different form maybe
you should have a worser habit than my
wife plus the nagging argument's sake I
know what I'm saying my wife has that
male blessed and preserver you know
amazing woman and now the point I'm
seeing is this though when the sisters
think that he's polygamous I'm gonna
leave and find another man he's not you
are dreaming that's man Eva marry
somebody who's in his 50s I'll say you
know what yeah now he's calmed down a
bit you know his Drive is calmed down a
bit maybe but if you are going to marry
somebody in their 30s I'm telling you
that man if you ask them I'm totally
okay darling yeah tell them look at the
camera if you sisters when your husband
and said I have a zero problem
or should I find her
that's what would happen are you going
to find out or should I find it simple
you know why because it's in our blood
it's not DNA so ital systems do not
destroy your marriages and I know
polygamies like the Somali Community
like alhamdulillah it is
so many brothers as long as long as they
are just no no as long as they are just
I'm so sorry I'm going to attention as
long as they are just I'm talking about
this very specific God-fearing man who
takes care of his wife who loves his
wife who looks after her not abusing her
not making her go do the shopping I'm
talking about a decent man of taqwa who
cares and loves his wife who is there
for his wife he's there for his kids
do not divorce this man because you are
not running away from the problem yeah
Ali can I just add sorry is there like a
condition to men because I find that
often men that are actually not even
provided for or doing well by the first
or doing right by first wife are getting
married left right and Center okay so so
I would say sister the moment you
violate the rights look a woman in Islam
has rights Allah has given that given
her rights that the Western women were
fighting 200 years ago to get do you
know in the in UK in this country a man
could go and sell his wife in the market
do you know that you can take it easy in
the UK there was a writing that he can
take his wife and say you know what I
have the internet's man I need I'm going
to tell my wife
so in Islam if a woman is and by the way
again I need to repeat that
um just so they see two types of people
don't learn the one who Shine the one is
arrogant that's why I mentioned this so
we're all adults here as well if a woman
is not sexually satisfied she has a
right to divorce if she comes and says I
am not satisfied from this man that man
can't cry because it's her hug so it's
very so people don't know this and I
think if I'm not mistaken a woman came
to the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him complaining about this so the
prophet didn't say how dare you immor
this woman
Prophet this is Islam this is not your
dead culture bars yeah whatever it is
yeah whatever culture you're from Islam
says she has her if she realizes hold on
a second this man doesn't provide for me
he doesn't even intimately please me
he's one against the second wife
sorry let's come back to this topic yeah
now the final topic is the following
uh when it comes to interracial
marriages I know there's this tribal
issue yeah we're going to talk about
we've got a whole episode of interracial
uh marriages as well yeah uh we're gonna
do but just in a nutshell with the
Somali Community how do you guys deal
with for example if there was a white
girl who's a river a a a Nigerian
brother Jamaican brother or a white
sister Nigerian sister how do you guys
deal with it
or is it how is it found upon is it yeah
yeah on this issue for me it's like um
how can I say first and foremost
interracial marriage is allowed it's
Halal in Islam yeah and it's highly
celebrated it's happening right but my
thing is this
understand this thing yeah if you want
to go all out Romeo and Juliet yeah what
do I mean do not listen to your parents
go outside your ethnicity
I mean there will be some issues your
grandma's type of food your mother's
type of food that type of food will no
longer be served yeah language barrier
yeah say goodbye to all of these in
smooth conversations it's all about
misunderstanding now I mean are we gonna
pretend yeah that you're gonna
understand your in-laws inside jokes
yeah my brother Google translate will
become your best friend yeah so in a
nutshell my thing is this if you want to
go all out interracial it's Halal yes
however it will come with a lot of love
laughter yeah Hard Times
miscommunication so and it's up to you
in the Somali Community we usually stick
to ourselves yeah yeah and we are very
homogeneous there is a saying when you
see a Somali you know he's a Somali or
she's a Somali there is a distinct look
yeah the phenotype so the thing is yeah
we like to stick together we only marry
each other
so and that's basically it okay now can
I just say Yes um I think it's
interesting that you have this approach
now
I came across a video of you
all right where you was talking about
um interracial marriage in such a
degrading and denigrating manner in
particular towards those who are of the
black race that you keep referring to as
right so there's a lot of anti-blackness
that exists within a Somali culture I
think we know that right and you kept on
mentioning there's a video that I saw of
you on my fyp unfortunately I don't know
how I came it says a lot more than that
yeah
let me just quickly say
um there's in that video you were saying
I would never let my daughter marry a
gerer you know this you know so it's
interesting how you suddenly now have a
different approach or very much or Islam
you know accepts it but you weren't
saying that in your video and first and
foremost I don't have a different
approach that particular video was a
comeback or a reaction video back to our
man yeah a man a general man who said I
will never let my daughter touch a
Somalia these Pirates banana eating big
foreheads I'll never let my daughter
touch one of these so what do what did I
do I did a comeback video that's
basically it no okay so okay if if you
if you okay
if you obviously
um he's saying I came from the angle
which is like um that they were being
racist towards or somalis yes that's
what he said he has a right defend
himself in that sense
um but let's just I understand your
concerns I understand I'm not gonna stop
you but let's just you know just go back
to like the Somali companies when it
comes to tribalism I think the strong
tribalism if I'm not mistaken um and by
the way we'll touch upon this just so
it's because you asked his world sister
maybe why don't you ask about myself and
this whole Somali thing that's happening
okay so this is for all of the Somali
Community
um I've let them know that I was coming
on and they wanted to know and they
believed that you have something against
the Somali community in particular the
Somali women so can you answer this Ali
because this is literally what they want
to know yeah to be honest I can give an
answer that will shut everyone up but
I'm just gonna go with the option b the
option b is basically that there's this
uh basically I don't know if you guys
saw my marriage documentary have you
heard of it no okay so marriage
documentary is my marriage my journey as
an orthodox Muslim to find finding my
wife so it's my journey I'm not
documented it this is what I went
through this is what happened this is
the good times the bad times when I was
broke so I'm just talking about ups and
downs and telling people how to go about
it and the less than life is they can
learn from what I've learned so in that
little instance the document the
documentary we've turned into a kind of
a docky drama so meaning is we have
certain actors on real life situations
that happened so what we did is we had a
Somali Uncle now the Somali uncle was
representing a real story that happened
to me there was a Somali system I was
getting to know for marriage very early
on when I first came to Islam it was in
a Haram relationship it was someone that
I had interest in it she had interested
in myself as well so there's perception
as if I liked her she didn't like me and
I'm hurt about it and I'm like oh no I
need to take care of this Somali
Community which I don't know where the
hell that came from number one
in Islam
to even bring it together then I have an
issue with the somalis is preposterous
because my Quran teachers and yes it's
something like oh my friend is black but
it's not like not only that it's I'm not
racist the point is the following we
done a part which was a short trainer
which is the Somali Uncle shouting at me
and saying stay away from my niece now
this is what really happened but what
I'm doing is I'm reenacting a certain
scene this happened to me with the
eritreans there was an area train system
I was getting off a marriage the same
thing happened there was a Bengali
system of marriage the same thing
happened but the pakistanis it wasn't
that bad yeah but I got racism Left
Right Center this was with a specific
Somali assistant that happened she
wanted to marry me and um there was a
problem that we wanted to marry but the
uncle didn't want it the uncle just
saying basically he's actually yeah so
basically like he's not I don't know
Foreigner
Etc and this that and look at the end of
the day I said to myself we can't go
ahead with this but I want when you
marry you marrying families exactly I
don't want your uncle is not happy
Etc so I cut it because to me it was
like it's not it's not really bad
exactly so that is where it's stemming
from and then there was a video about I
don't know say it the the Somali yes yes
so he made a comment about the African
Americans or we don't they don't know
who their fathers are then this
African-American
it's my fault me I was quoting him
seeing Somali girls
I was defending I was saying how could
you say this is slander yeah so they
were like oh why are you tightening like
that so from there onwards there's this
person yeah it's a perception but it
mainly comes from the non-practice in
somalis I've realized and then I was
trending on Twitter people were like
alhamdulillah the uncle rejected you
um exception and I thought to myself
look I understand I never ever offended
all I'm just saying is this is a story
that happened I don't have animal
animosity it was just this is what
happened yeah this is how I dealt with
it yeah Anna moved on yeah that was it
but that's where it's stemming from
right so other than that anyone that
knows me come on man like I'm so sorry
man like who knows me my favorite
comments
anyone that says out of their mind they
should go they
it's impossible so that's where it stems
from okay um but going back to the topic
of international marriages tribalism
um is that right like I've heard that
you guys are married from different
tribes on my right room yeah the tribes
of such a big issue about our community
I think it's it's utterly disgusting I I
like literally you know I think
hopefully everyone on the panel
um is we we don't like that sort of
stuff yeah we're trying to move away
from that but there are people that are
still very very strong in in their Kabir
and they're like we're not going to
marry this we're not going to marry that
obvious so
way of saying they're inferior to us you
know yeah
your lineage is short and basically but
it's used
but it's an insult right for people it's
not a good word yeah I don't like it
yeah
if you was argument saying if you guys
was to marry a a non-somali
how would the family like no not you
guys specifically just how do they deal
with okay this person are they more like
okay with the specific race like if it's
a White River are they okay with it or
if it's like a
Jamaican or black or I don't know like
is it is it change or is it yeah I mean
nowadays there are more and more Somali
people men and women
um particularly now that we've got the
the world of tick tock looking so I can
see a lot more
acceptable yeah and parents I've seen
I've spoken to like a few older parents
and they've said my daughter's got
married to a black man and I'm I'm as
long as my daughter is happy and I and I
and I congratulate her because that
ultimately that's all that matters at
the end of the day my in my personal
opinion is is this person going to look
after your your daughter or you know
vice versa
um I think it's become a lot more
accepting but yeah certainly I think
maybe some Races they probably think is
inferior inferior and they're probably
more accepting of a white man perhaps in
the smaller Community yeah um someone
may be more closer to that has already
um Islam in like if they're Muslim
already yeah it's yeah but anyways okay
that's I don't think there's anything
else to be uh I don't is there anything
that we need something about the Somali
culture and if you know
okay that's interesting a lot of people
come and say oh Somali is black or no
foreign
no
no okay
anyways guys it was a pleasure thank you
very much guys may Allah bless you
Council all the way from Sweden we need
more in the show inshallah
till next time sisters on the bitty trip
show if you guys want we want different
coaches one Moroccans algerians turfs
cards uh Nigerians uh Congolese whatever
please apply and we would love to have
you guys on the show and know about your
cultural like we did with our Somali
brothers and sisters until next time
so guys if you are somebody who trains
like me and
eat when I'm joking when I'm doing
bodybuilding this can benefit you it's
from Nature's Blends as you guys know I
get my honey my black seed oil and many
other supplements from them it has 86
plus minerals including zinc magnesium
selenium fulvic acid and 59 fully lab
tested the highest in the market boost
testosterone levels Boost energy levels
and safe for men and women so check out
Nature's Blends in the description box
and enjoy it